The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
YEN-JIE LEE: So
let's get started.
This is our goal for 8.03.
So you can see, during
the exam number one,
we have covered the
first half of the goal,
and we are actually
making progress
to learn about
boundary conditions
in one dimensional
system and also
in two dimensional system today.
And we will actually talk
about phenomena related
to electromagnetic
waves and optics
today, which we will
be able to learn
two very important
fundamental laws related
to geometrical optics.
OK, so that's the excitement.
And then we started a discussion
of two dimensional or three
dimensional wave last time.
And just in case you
haven't realized that,
there are two ways to
go to higher dimension.
So the first way is to
increase the number of objects
and place that in two
dimensional or three
dimensional space.
And that is the kind of things
which you will discuss today.
So for example, I
can have particles
arranged in two dimensions
which form membranes.
And then we can also,
on the other hand,
change the direction of
the electromagnetic wave,
for example, as a
function of time,
and that's another way to
go to a higher dimension.
And today, as I
mentioned before, we
are going to talk about the
first case, and on Thursday
we are going to talk
about the second way
to go to higher dimension, which
is related to polarization,
et cetera.
In general, higher order
dimensions are hopeless.
They are super complicated.
And, in general, we
don't really know how
to solve this kind of system.
Fortunately, in 8.03,
what we have been doing
is focusing on a small subset of
questions of which are actually
highly symmetric.
Therefore, we can actually
solve it analytically.
So that will be
the focus of 8.03,
so that we can actually learn
some physics intuition out
of this kind highly
idealized system.
And the system which we
are going to focus on today
is shown here.
It's a two dimensional
system, which
you have array of masses
placing the x and y, x, y plan.
And that is the system we
are going to solve today.
And we will learn a lot of
interesting phenomena coming
from the solution of
this kind of system.
Before we start a discussion
of two dimensional system,
I would like to remind you
of what we have already
learned from lecture eight.
So that was about a system which
consists of infinite number
of mass and the infinite number
of strings, and each string
have string tension T.
And all the mass, when
they are in
equilibrium position,
the distance between all
those mass in the x direction
is a, OK?
So we have solved this system
before with space translation
symmetry.
And this is just a reminder that
the dispersion relation, which
we got a lot time, omega,
as a function of k,
is t over ma sine Ka over 2.
So that was just a
reminder of what we have
learned from lecture eight.
So by now you should
realize that, OK,
dispersion relation is unusual.
This is actually
telling you that this
is a dispersive media, right?
Because if you calculate
the ratio of omega and k,
you'll see that this is
actually not a constant.
So after all the discussion
from previous lecture,
you should be able to
immediately realize that.
And any wave propagating
on this kind of system,
there will be a dispersion
phenomena happening
in this kind of system.
OK?
And also from the
previous lecture,
we'll have learned that
the eigenvectors based
on space translation
symmetry, it's
exponential of ikx, where x
is defined as j times a, where
it's a is a label to
tell you what which mass
I was talking about.
Now today, we are
going to extend this
to a two dimensional system.
So instead of a one
dimensional system
we have a two dimensional array.
So all the little mass
all have mass equal to n,
and they are placing xy plan.
The coordinate system,
which I defined is here.
x is horizontal, and
the y is vertical,
and the z is actually
pointing to you.
And all those
little mass can only
oscillate toward you
or going away from you,
so in the z direction.
It can only oscillate up
and down in the z direction.
And in this system we have
the length scale, which
is the horizontal distance
between mass, is called aH.
And in the vertical
direction, the scale
of the distance
between mass is av.
Also, we have string tension--
two different kinds
of string tension
for the vertical and
horizontal direction.
The vertical direction,
you have string tension Tv,
and in the horizontal direction
you have string tension Th.
OK
So how do we actually describe
this kind of system, right?
The first thing,
as we did before,
is to label those
little mass by my label.
And my label is
called Jx and Jy,
which tells you which mass I was
talking about in this system.
Once I have defined
that, the labels,
I will be able to write the
position of all those mass,
the x direction position
and y direction position,
in terms of J and the
A. So for example,
x position of 1 over the mass
will be written as Jx times ah.
And y position of
a specific mass,
you can write it down in
terms of a Jy times av.
So all those things should
be pretty straight forward.
The interesting
part is that, as we
identified in the last
lecture, this system
is highly symmetric.
It has space translation
symmetry, right?
Therefore, we can actually
immediately figure out
what will be the
eigenvectors for this system.
So the eigenvector--
very similar to what
has been discussed here,
where you have a one
dimensional space
translation symmetric system.
Exponential of ikx
was the eigenvector.
Now you have eigenvector
which is in two dimension,
because you would
like to describe
not only the x direction
but also y direction.
And the eigenvector have
exactly the same functional form
because of space
translational symmetry,
and it is like exponentional
of ixk times x.
Multiply that by another
exponential function--
exponential iky times y.
So I think, until now,
nothing should surprise you
because this is what we
have learned from the one
dimensional system analysis.
Based on what we
have learned before,
we can also
immediately write down
what would be the
dispersion relation.
Since we are always considering
very small vibration,
and this formula
is still applies,
therefore you can actually write
down the dispersion relation--
omega squared k will be equal
to 4 Th over Mah sine square Kx
Ah, divided by 2 plus 4 Tv
divided by Mav sine square Ky
Av divided by 2.
So this is actually
pretty straightforward.
And you can see that omega is a
function of both Kx and the Ky.
From the eigenvector
we can also write down
what would be the
possible Psi xy.
Now the Psi is actually
the displacement
in the z direction, with respect
to the equilibrium position.
And that is actually
proportional
to the eigenvector.
So basically it's going to
be a exponential ikx times x
exponential iky times y.
And of course I can write these
two terms together, right?
So basically what I would
get is a exponential i,
k is a vector times
r, which is a vector.
So basically k contains
two components, Kx and Ky,
and r have also two
components, which is x and y.
Again, we see that this is
actually a non dispersive
medium.
And what we are going to do
is to make linear combination
of all those eigenvectors
and figure out
what would be the behavior
when this system is oscillating
at a specific frequency
omega, and that is actually
the corresponding normal mode
at the angular frequency omega.
So that is actually pretty
similar to what we have done
for one dimensional system.
So this is a two
dimensional system.
Just a reminder about one
dimensional system for a while.
So there are two
eigenvectors which
have identical omega, right?
So the first one
is exponential ikx,
and the second one is
exponential of minus ikx.
What we have done
before is to do
a linear combination of the two
exponential functions, right?
So what we can do is that--
OK, now I can create cosine Kx.
This is actually 1
over 2 exponential ikx
plus exponential minus ikx.
Or I can also create sine Kx.
And this is actually 1
over 2i, exponential ikx
minus exponential minus ikx,
for this one dimensional system.
So that's how we figure
out when the system is
doing one of the normal mode.
The shape of the system is
like a cosine or a sine.
Or in general, you can
add these two together,
and in general it
can be something
like cosine Kx plus
5, but 5 is actually
some phase angle, which
you can figure out
by boundary condition.
But before we introduce
any boundary condition,
all the k values, all the
five values are allowed.
Just a reminder about what
we have learned before.
So the situation
is pretty simple.
You have just plus
and minus k, and then
you make linear
combination of these two,
then you know what will be
the shape of the normal mode.
On the other hand,
we are now talking
about two dimensional case.
So let's take a look at
this dispersion relation.
The dispersion relation
we will have here, omega
is a function of Kx, is
a function of Ky as well.
OK, what does that mean?
That means I can have
multiple choice of Kx and Ky,
which they all produce
the same omega value.
So it's not as
simple as this one
any more, as you can see, right?
Because when I slightly increase
Kx, what I could do is--
OK, I can slightly reduce Ky
to compensate the difference.
Therefore, I can
still keep omega,
which is the angular frequency
of the oscillation the same.
OK, so that can be seen
from this demonstration
on the slide.
You can see that this is
actually one example dispersion
relation.
This is actually the formula
which we have on the board.
And what about if I set all
those parameters and get,
example, omega squared
equal to 5 sine squared Kx,
and the plus 5 sine squared Ky?
OK, so what will happen?
If I set my aht and the m value,
so that I have this example.
What will happen if I have
that dispersion relation?
So if I go ahead, and then
plot allowed Kx and Ky
value, which gives 1, you see a
very beautiful pattern, right,
on this.
So you can see that ha, all
those things on the circle
can produce angular
frequency omega equal to 1.
And 1 will be their--
1 will be the--
normal mode will be
all possible linear combination
of all those possible Kx, Ky
pairs.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YEN-JIE LEE: In
general, I think this--
you mean a circular shape?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YEN-JIE LEE: I think,
in general, yes,
you do have determinacy
because you can--
but the shape will not
be circular, for example.
OK, so it can be
a general function
which is like the formula
above, but this argument still
applies.
So if you have some
intermediate omega value,
you can always slightly increase
Kx and slightly decrease Ky,
and that will still satisfy
the same omega value.
Therefore, all the
normal modes, we
set specific omega will be
a linear combination of all
those possible normal mode.
All those possible Kx
and Ky pairs if you
have an infinitely long system.
And the law also applies
to the other example, when
I have omega equal
to 5, then you have
slightly different behavior.
But the take home
message is that there
are many, many
pairs of Kx and Ky,
which can create the
same amount of omega.
So that makes things
pretty complicated.
Potentially, we can
always still try
to understand this
by investigating
all the possible k
pairs of Kx and Ky.
On the other hand--
this is what we have
discussed before.
Before you introduce
boundary condition
for the one dimensional
system, there
are infinite number of
possible k value, right?
All the possible k
values are allowed.
But after you add boundary
condition-- for example,
I add walls around this system,
so that I basically have
a fixed boundary condition.
So basically, the
boundary condition
is that the amplitude at x
equal to 0, y equal to 0, or x
equal to 5ah or y equal to 4av.
At the boundary, the amplitude
has to be equal to 0,
because it is
attached to a wall.
OK, when this happens
this means that we
will have have four
wall which will
have a corresponding
boundary condition.
So that means I have to
satisfy this four boundary
consideration of side 0,y
evaluated at any time will be
equal to Psi Lh, y, t,
will be equal to Psi x,0,t,
will be equal to Psi x,Lv,t.
And this is all equal to 0.
So those are not very
difficult to understand.
Those are just the four
walls around the system.
Once you have all
those conditions--
and of course I define Lh
will be equal to 5 times Ah,
because there are 5 strings
between the two walls
in the horizontal direction.
And of course I also
have defined here,
Lv will be 4 times equal to av.
So once I have all those four
boundary conditions in place
that means I cannot arbitrarily
choose k value and the fact,
right?
Otherwise, I will not be able
to satisfy these four boundary
conditions.
So now we actually will
be able to figure out
that there will be only
four modes in this two
dimensional problem, which
will give the same omega.
What are the four
possible nodes--
what are the four
possible eigenvectors?
Those are a exponential
plus or minus ikx
times x, exponential plus minus
iky times y, where the Kx--
because of the
boundary condition,
which we have solved in the
one dimensional system--
Kx will be equal to
Nx pi divided by Lh--
in order to match the boundary
condition, add x equal to 0
and x equal to Lh.
And Ky will be equal to
y times pi divided by Lv.
That's actually
designed to match
the boundary condition
at y equal to 0
and then y equal to Lv.
So you can see that,
like when we've
seen before with one dimensional
system, after you introduced
the boundary condition it's not
an infinity long system anymore
that allowed k value, which
is the length number in the x
and y direction.
For example, in this case,
it's also become limited,
and only a limited number of
possible values are allowed.
In this case, Nx is allowed
to be equal to 1, 2 until 4,
and Ny is equal 1,2,3 in this
system we are talking about.
Any questions so far?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: I think you
mentioned that Kx and Ky are
directly related rather
than inversely related,
but I'm sort of confused
as to why that is.
Because if you want to
maintain the frequency,
it increases the wave
numer and [INAUDIBLE]..
YEN-JIE LEE: Yeah,
so I was talking
about when I choose Kx and Ky
in the infinitely long system.
OK, all of the possible
values of Kx and Ky
are allowed because I have
a infinitely long system
with no boundary condition.
And in that case, going back
to this dispersion relation,
I have the freedom to--
OK, so when I increase
a little bit, Kx,
I can always decrease
a little bit, the Ky.
OK, so the question is why
that's not the case, right,
for the discrete case.
As you can see from here, after
we introduced the boundary
condition, the four
boundary conditions
especially describe the
boundary of the four walls.
And what is going to happen
is that you will also see that
the allowed Kx value
is becoming limited,
because you cannot arbitrarily
choose with lengths, right,
if you choose a side along the
wavelengths like what we have
been trying to do for the
infinitely long system--
not that it matched
the boundary condition.
Therefore, you don't have
this degree of freedom
to choose slightly
higher or slightly lower
Ky when I change a Kx.
So you can see that the
allowed value are discrete.
Therefore, the number
of possible combinations
of Kx and Ky is also limited.
And in this case, it's
actually very likely
to be limited to be only
four pairs, which is actually
plus, minus Kx and
the plus, minus Ky.
All right.
Thank you for the question.
OK, then once I
have those I can do
a linear combination of these
four possible eigenvectors.
And also, at the
same time, I will
try to match the
boundary condition.
So if I jump forward,
basically what you can conclude
is that Psi Nx and y, so
that's with an Nx value y
value chosen for the
determination of Kx and Ky.
And is this actually a function
of x and y and of course also
time, when I also
make it oscillate
as a function of time.
This will be equal to
some arbitrary constant, A
of amplitude Nx,
Ny sine Nx pi x,
divided by Lh sine Ny
times y divided by Lv.
And of course, you can see that
this is actually sine, right?
It's actually, the same as
what we have done for the one
dimensional system, right?
So if you have two boundary
conditions that said,
look, the beginning
and the end, therefor,
the corresponding normal mode
is always a sine function.
So that's what we have
learned from the one
dimensional system.
And this is also the case for
the two dimensional system.
And of course, don't
forget this wave function
is changing as a
function of time
oscillating up and
down harmonically.
Therefore, you have sine omega
Nx, Ny times T plus Theta,
which is a phase
to be determined
by initial conditions.
And you can see that the
whole equation, a sine sine
is multiplied by a sine
omega T plus 5 because
of beta function, right?
So that means the
shape is actually
going up and down harmonically.
So the shape is fixed,
which is sine times sine,
and the whole thing
is oscillating
at the same frequency
at the same phase, which
is the definition of
normal mode, right?
Just a reminder.
And how do we actually imagine
what is actually happening?
That brings me to
the demonstration,
so we can really visualize
how this kind of system
will look like by a
little simulation.
So, suppose I choose
Nx and Ny equal to 1
and see what will happen.
This is the kind of oscillation
you will expect, right?
So if you choose Nx equal
to 1, Ny equal to 1,
then this is a system.
Basically you have sine
function with no node
in x and y direction.
Therefore, if you do
get this simulation,
you can see that there will
be no node in the x,y plane,
and all those particles
are either going toward you
or going away from you.
They only oscillate in the z
direction in this simulation.
And also, you can see that now
I can increase, for example--
I can increase the Kx by
setting Nx to be 2 and see
what will happen.
So what is going to happen
is that if I have higher
Kx in the x direction-- so the
next possible normal mode is
that you have a full sine
wave in the x direction, then
you are going to
see two components
in this demonstration.
And one part of the system
is actually moving toward you
while the other half
part of the system
is actually moving
away from you.
And you can actually see
the node, or nodal line
in this case, because
we are talking
about a two dimensional
system in the middle
of the distribution.
Of course, we can
always go crazy, right?
I can set this to a
really high value.
So in this case,
the highest value
I can set these is 3 and
4, and see what happens.
And this is actually
a beautiful shape
which is actually complicated
but understandable, as you
see in this demonstration.
And all those little
particles in this system
are oscillating up and down
at the same angular frequency
and also at the same phase.
Any questions?
OK, so now we have done
the discrete case, right?
And of course we can also
go to the continuous case.
So if we go to a
continuous limit,
now I can assume that
there is a symmetry
between a horizontal direction
and the vertical direction.
I assume that Th is equal
to Tv is equal to T.
And also I assume that the
length scale in the x direction
and the y directions is
equal, and the length scale
is A. In order to make the
whole system continuous,
I need to increase the number
of objects in the system,
and at the same time I also
need to decrease the distance
between all those objects.
So therefore, I need to have--
this length scale goes to 0.
And what is going to
happen is that if I rewrite
my omega, which is a dispersion
relation, what I am going
to get is 4T divided by
Na Kx squared, A squared,
divided by 4, plus 4T over Na,
Ky squared a squared over 4.
This is issue
because I am taking--
Ah and V need to be equal
to-- and also having
to be a very, very small value.
Therefore, sine theta
is roughly theta, right?
Therefore, I can immediately
write down this expression.
And this will be equal to
Ta divided by N, Kx squared
plus Ky squared.
So we are facing exactly
the same situation.
When I decrease A, I am
going to add more objects
into the system,
but I don't want
to have an infinitely
large mass.
Therefore, I also
need to ensure the fix
the ratio of m and a, so
that when I actually increase
the number of objects, I don't
actually make the total mass
go to infinity.
So what I could do is I can
define Rho S is actually
the surface mass density.
So the surface mass
density is defined
as m divided by a squared.
And I can also define
a surface tension.
Surface tension Ts will
be equal to T over a.
And in this case, basically,
I will be able to control,
so that when I increase
the number of objects,
mass doesn't go
to infinity, and I
have constant surface tension
and constant surface mass
density.
If I have defined
this to quantity
then this will become Ts
divided by Rho S Kx squared
plus Ky squared,
and this will be
equal to Ts divided by
Rho S, k vector squared.
And this k vector is a
two dimensional vector.
So we are actually almost
there to make it continuous.
So now I can make a goes
to a very small value.
We fixed the Ts
and the row S. Very
similar to what we have learned
from the one dimensional case.
Basically what we
actually found is
that time in the
one dimensional case
is that M minus 1 K metrics
become minus T over Rho
L, partial squared,
partial x squared
in the one dimensional case.
And in the two dimensional
case, without working
through all the detail
of mass, basically
what we are going to get
is partial square partial T
square Psi xy--
It's actually a function
of x and y and the time,
right, because this is actually
a two dimensional system.
And this will be equal to
V squared, partial squared,
partial x squared plus partial
squared, partial y squared,
Psi xy and T--
very similar to
what we have done
for the one dimensional system.
And of course I can, as you
define this, as del squared.
And basically what you are
going to get is V squared,
del squared, Psi x,y,t.
So basically we again
see this wave equation,
but this wave equation is now a
two dimensional wave equation.
And we can also figure out what
will be the V value, right,
so what will be the velocity?
The velocity which is going
to be square root of Ts
over Rho S. This is very
similar what we have done
for the continuous case, and
in this case, what replaced
T over Rho L is Ts
over Rho S. Therefore,
what we actually see that if I
increase the surface tension,
then the velocity will increase.
If I decrease the
mass per unit area,
Rho S, then I will be able to
have a much faster traveling
wave from this kind of media.
And what we can actually
immediately also write down
is that the Psi will be
proportional to A sine Kx
times x, sine Ky times y,
and Psi omega T plus 5,
where omega is calculated
from the input Kx and Ky
for this standing wave solution.
And very similarly, I
can also argue that--
in the three dimensional
case I can actually
follow exactly
the same argument.
Basically, in the
three dimensional case,
as well, we already see in
the electromagnetic wave
discussion, the three
dimensional wave equation can
be written as partial
squared, partial T squared
Psi is a function of
x, y, and z and T.
And this will be equal to
V squared, partial squared,
partial x squared plus partial
squared, partial y squared
plus partial squared,
partial V squared--
Psi is a function of x,y,z,
and T. Any questions so far?
Nope?
OK, so everything is
crystal clear, right?
OK, so this is actually
the animation, which
I showed you before already.
So this is actually the
two dimensional vibration
of membranous.
So basically the first one
is what I have shown you
when I choose a very
small K value, which
only make half of
the sign and which
match the boundary condition.
Basically you see that
there are oscillation,
which you have the
middle part, which
is either going toward
you or going away from you
in this continuous system.
So basically the solution is
actually remarkably the same
as what we have seen
in the discrete system.
OK, that's actually
what I wanted to say.
And also, of course, you
can increase the k value,
so that you go to the higher
frequency normal mode.
And you can see that if you
have more and more nodal
lines, which is actually
the lines describing the--
the lines which you
actually have no oscillation
at all on the surface.
For example, in this
case, the nodal lines,
as you're passing through
the middle of this figure--
because all those little mass,
all the other high particles
are vibrating like crazy.
But all the particles on
this line, the nodal line,
they're not at all moving,
because that's actually
at this position--
which is having one of the
sine function equal to 0.
Therefore, no matter what
you do as a function of time,
how you evolve the system, all
those particle at that line
will not move at all.
And this was demonstrated
from this table here.
It's actually Chladni figures.
You can see that in a
two dimensional case
the figures can look
very complicated.
So basically what
it's showing here
is that you have a
square plate and it's
attached to a vibrator,
and basically this vibrator
can be controlled.
I can change the frequency
of that vibration.
When I reach resonance, which
excites one of the normal mode,
then this plate
will be oscillating
in a specific pattern.
And those lines are
actually showing you
that the plates, which you
have no oscillation at all
as a function of time.
Because if I, for example,
turn on this demo again,
you can see that if
I turn on this demo--
you can see that all
the sand on the plates
are vibrating because
now I am oscillating
this plate by the vibration
generator and the button--
by the motor and the button.
And if I change the
oscillation frequency so
you can see that this frequency
doesn't match with one
of the normal mode frequency.
Therefore, they will not
be a lot of activity.
But if I now change
the frequency,
so that it matches with one
of the oscillation frequency
for one of the normal
mode of this system,
you can see the, oh, some really
cryptic pattern is formed!
You can see that, oh, it have
a very complicated pattern.
And if I put my finger
in one of the lines
here I don't feel the vibration,
but on the other hand,
if I put my finger
here, I can actually
feel that there's lot of
vibration at that point.
I can always change
the frequency
and see what will happen.
And then you can see that
now I increase the frequency,
and now I am actually trying
to excite another mode.
Now I need some more sand.
You can see that I randomly
throw sand on this plate,
and then you can see that
those centered as you bounce it
around until it sits on
the nodal line, which
no vibration actually happens.
OK, so let's go back to one of
the lower frequency mode, which
we showed you before.
Now the question is, OK, you
can see this complicated pattern
almost look ridiculous, can we
actually reproduce this pattern
by our calculation?
So we have seen that, OK, I can
conclude that the normal mode
looks like this, right?
So therefore, I must
be able to explain
all those patterns,
which is actually
shown in this experiment.
So that's actually what I am
going to do to give you a try.
So this is a little
demonstration
which I actually wrote.
This demonstration actually
has the solution to this two
dimensional problem.
And also the boundary
condition is that--
or say, the condition which,
as you can see on my solution,
is that I require the center
of the plate to be driven,
because that's where I
start to vibrate this plate.
And I drive this plate
up and down to see
what is going to happen.
So from this
analytical calculation
you can see that you expect a
circle in the middle and also
four lines which actually
cover this circle.
And also there are
some strange structure
at the edge of the plate.
And you can actually
compare this calculation
to this result. It doesn't
really match perfectly.
So you can see that there
is some imperfection,
but you get that
ring in the middle,
and you do see these
1-2-3-4-5-6-7-8,
8 lines produced
in this experiment.
So this experiment is not
perfect because there's a,
you know, stiffness
of this thing
and also some energy
dissipation, et cetera.
But you can see
that, sort of, we
can actually use our calculation
to explain this pattern!
That's really cool, right?
And the advantage is that now I
have this wonderful simulation.
I can put in all
the crazy numbers,
and you see that, huh, if
I increase the K value,
I can really make all kinds
of ridiculous patterns out
of this.
And all these things can be kind
of realized by this experiment.
So you can see
that, for example,
I can now also turn on
this, and I can actually
increase the frequency to a very
high frequency, for example.
Then I can see that,
oh, the pattern really
becomes much more complicated.
Now I have a circle and there
are many, many more structures
which you're seeing in
the surrounding area.
And of course I can
again increase, increase,
and see what happens.
I don't know what is going to
happen because every time I
do this experiment I
get a different pattern.
OK, now this seems to be
a very nice frequency.
It's getting harder and harder.
You can see that
this is really crazy.
Holy mackerel, right?
What the hell is this?
So you can see that all those
crazy patterns can be created.
And of course,
during the break, you
are welcome to come
forward and play with this.
So you can see that
we can actually
understand, sort of, the pattern
produced from this experiment.
That's actually very exciting,
because that's actually
why we are physicists, right?
We would like to know why
those patterns are formed,
and now you know why.
Those patterns are
formed because there
are nodal lines in this two
dimensional normal mode modes.
And the little sands
really love to sit there,
because you want to sit
in a place which you
don't have a lot of vibration.
It's not very
comfortable, right?
So you sit in the place,
which, hm, vibrates?
Your problem.
Vibrate's your problem.
I sit here where
there is no vibration.
So that's basically how we
explain these strange figures
which we can see.
And just for fun you can
see that I can also generate
all kinds of craziness.
You can input all kinds of
different Nx and Ny values,
and you get all those
wonderful figures for free.
Maybe we can actually
make some T-shirts
with all those figures
on the T-shirt, right?
OK, so we had a lot of fun with
this two dimensional plate.
How about what will happen
if I have a circular plate?
What does it do?
Unfortunately, I would not
be able to solve the two
dimensional plate
problem in front of you
because that will give you a
Bessel function, which is not
the end of the world, but that's
actually kind of complicated.
If I put it in mid-term
exam, that's actually not
very encouraging, right?
But I can actually tell you
what will be the solution.
The solution will be
a Bessel function.
Basically you will have a
lot of ring-like structures
if I have a circular plate.
And I can actually do an
experiment which actually shows
you the behavior of the
circular boundary condition
and see what kind of
pattern can we see.
So here I have a kind of
complicated experiment.
So here I have
this ring, which I
would like to produce
some film on this ring.
So see if I am successful.
Kind of.
OK.
Now I can put this a soft
film in front of the speaker.
I can actually
oscillate this thing--
membranes by the speaker.
Oops, don't want to
destroy everything here.
All right, so now I can turn
on this, so that we have light.
And of course I will turn
on the signal generator,
so that I can hear--
I can actually start to
vibrate the membranes.
Before I do that, I have to turn
everything off, hide images.
All right, I hope you
can see something.
Can you?
Can you see something on the--
it's kind of difficult to see
it, but that should be there.
OK, now I can turn
on this speaker,
and you can see that there
are some patterns which
it's probably difficult to see.
Kind of see, right?
There are rings.
You can see it on the speaker.
So you can see that now I have
one, two, three-- three rings,
right?
Because I couldn't turn off
the light, which is actually
emitted from the sun, right?
So I cannot turn off sun.
Therefore, you can
barely see this figure.
So we shall explain the
result of this experiment.
And you can see that if
I increase the frequency,
according to the solution
from Bessel function,
you will see more
rings got excited.
So you can see that now
I have one, two, three,
four-- four rings.
And of course I can continue
to increase, increase,
and increase.
And you will see that there
are even more rings produced.
Essentially what I'm
doing is actually really
trying to vibrate and excite
one of the normal mode
by this loud speaker.
And you can actually
kind of see--
I hope you can kind of see it.
If you can still
see it, that means
you need to check your eye
because the membranes is
broken.
OK, so I think you
sort of get this idea,
and I'm going to turn off
this wonderful machine
and go back to the lecture.
So this experiment is kind of
hard to reproduce in your study
room, right?
I think everybody will agree.
And there's another
one which is actually
kind of easy to
reproduce, which I
will encourage you to try it--
so if you have time.
So this is from Jake.
He sent me this
wonderful video when
I was teaching the 8.03 class.
They found that they could
excite two dimensional waves
in this way.
Can you see it?
It's wonderful.
You can see there are very high
frequency oscillation, which
actually excite these
two dimensional wave.
And you can see that lots,
and lots, and lots of rings
are excited.
And then you can
see very clearly
from this simple
experiment, what you really
need is a cup of water.
And you rub it against the
surface of a table, then
you'll be able to excite all
the crazy patterns, which
you can actually see from
this two dimensional system
and with two dimensional
boundary conditions.
OK, so we will
take a five minute
break before we enter the
next part of the discussion.
And we come back at 35.
OK, welcome back, everybody.
So what I'm going to do now
is to continue the discussion,
the one we actually got
started, of the two dimensional
and three dimensional system.
And we have actually
studied the behavior
of standing wave,
or normal mode,
for this two dimensional system.
And what I am going to do
is discuss with you, a two
dimensional progressive wave.
So I will stick to a
really simple example,
which are plane waves.
OK, so in the case of plane
waves, which we discussed when
we actually discussed
the EM waves,
you have the following
functional form.
Psi is a function
of r and the t.
And this will be equal
to A exponential i.
The k is a vector
now, and it's pointing
to the direction of the
propagation of this plan wave.
And this k is dot with r
vector minus omega T, which
is the oscillation
frequency-- angular frequency.
And evaluated at
a specific time.
And this is expression
actually describes a plane wave
where the direction
of propagation
is described by this k vector.
And of course you can
actually have the wave front,
which is actually the peak
position of this plain wave.
And the distance between
the peak position--
so if you can imagine
that this is like this.
So if you look at the
distance between peak position
that will give you the
wavelengths, right?
The wavelengths,
now that will be
equal to 2 pi
divided by k, right?
In this case, it's the
length of this k vector.
Just a reminder about
what we introduced
in the previous lecture.
And we were using this to
describe electromagnetic wave
and such a kind of
expression can be also
be used to describe
sound waves and also
vibration on the membranes,
et cetera, progressive waves.
So if there are no other
medium like what we actually
have in this slide--
so we have nothing else.
I have a membrane with
a surface tension Ts,
and Rho S is the
mass per unit area.
Then basically, this
progressing wave
is going to be traveling
at the speed of v,
which is equal to square
root of Ts over Rho S,
and I can actually define that
to be some constant c divided
by n.
So c is some constant,
and m is another constant
which actually, the ratio
c and n is equal to v.
And I will need that expression
later, only later, not now.
If I have nothing else and
that this system actually
filled the whole universe,
then what is going to happen
is that this progressing
wave is going
to be propagating, propagating,
propagating, propagating.
Nothing will change until
the edge of the universe.
It doesn't actually
introduce any excitement.
So that's what we
have already learned
from when we have discussed
electromagnetic interaction,
and now the same
expression can also
be used for the description
of the membranes.
And then now to make this
problem more exciting,
what I'm going to do is
to introduce a boundary.
So the boundary is in
the middle of this slide.
And I will assume that
the horizontal direction
to be x equal to 0--
the horizontal direction to be
in x direction and the boundary
is at x equal to 0.
And when you pass
this boundary, there's
another kind of material
with surface tension Ts prime
and slightly different mass
per unit area, your s prime.
Based on the expression
we got for the velocity
we will be able to
conclude that v prime will
be equal to square root of T
prime S divided by Rho S prime.
And that will be equal
to c over n prime.
And c is the same constant which
I used for the left hand side
system.
And n, later, you will realize
that that's a refraction
index in a discussion.
So the question which
I would like to ask
is, OK, now I have a
prime wave propagating
in the first system.
And it met a boundary,
and the question
is what will happen when I
have the incident wave coming
into the system?
So before that, I also need
to write down the dispersion
relation, right.
So dispersion relation
can be attempted
by plugging in a normal
mode Psi function
into the wave equation.
So what I can
immediately obtain is
that the dispersion
relation, omega squared
is equal to V squared, Kx
squared, plus Ky squared.
You can actually
check this expression
by plugging in this function
into the two dimensional wave
equation, and you will
get that expression, OK?
And that means omega
cannot be arbitrary number.
It's as you decided
by Kx and the Ky.
Or say, if omega is the side
and one of the k is the side,
then the third number, for
example in this case, Kx,
is as you decided by
the dispersion relation
which we have here.
So, coming back to the original
problem we are posting,
I have, now, the incident
wave coming into this system.
I would like to know what
will happen at the boundary
when I have two systems with a
left hand side propagating at--
the speed of the
propagation is v,
and right hand side's speed
of propagation is v prime.
What is going to happen?
Assume my guess that I am
going to get a refractive wave
and a transmitted wave.
So that's based on what we
have learned from the one
dimensional system.
If I call this the left hand
side, and call the right hand
side system right hand--
the right hand system, r.
So I can write down the wave
function Psi L describing
the left hand side.
This will be equal to A
exponential of ik dot r
minus omega T. This is
actually the incident wave--
describing this incident wave.
And as you might
guess, there should be
some kind of refraction, right?
So once this wave
actually passed
through the boundary,
or touch the boundary,
there should be some kind
of refraction, right?
So the refraction, I can
actually write it down
in this form as sum
over alpha, r alpha
is actually the coefficient
over amplitude as function
of the normal modes--
as a function of the
progressing wave number,
which I have shown.
And I can actually
sum over all kinds
of progressing wave numbers.
Exponential ik alpha
times r minus omega T.
So this is a general
form of refracting wave.
k alpha is describing
the direction
of the individual
refractive wave,
and alpha is labeling the
individual refractive wave.
But I don't know what will
be the functional form
for the k alpha for the moment.
So therefore, I try to sum
over all the possible alpha.
And I would like
to figure out what
will be the allowed alpha
by matching the boundary
condition.
So in short, the
right hand side turn
essentially is actually
describing the refractive wave.
And finally, passing through
this boundary condition,
let's look at the
right hand side.
Right hand side, Psi
r, is going to be
sum over beta on the
transmission coefficients tau
beta, which is the original
amplitude, exponential of i,
k beta times r minus
omega T. So again I
don't know what
will be the behavior
of the transmitted wave.
Therefore, I have summed
over all the possible values.
And this is actually
the functional form
for the transmitted wave.
I also know that k alpha
vector squared will
be equal to omega
squared Rho s over Ts,
and this will be equal to
omega squared v squared,
because of the dispersion
relation in the left hand side.
So basically, if you look at
the left hand side dispersion
relation, the length
squared of this k vector
will be equal to omega squared
times v squared, right?
This is just a
dispersion relation
of a non-dispersive medium.
And also, I can actually
figure out what will be the--
allowed length for the k theta.
So the k theta squared will
be equal to omega squared
v prime square, because this
progressing wave is actually
the transmitted
wave, is actually
traveling in a second medium.
So look at what
we have done here.
So we have an incident wave.
We will wonder, then,
what is going to happen.
Our physics intuition
tells me that, you
must get a refracting
wave, oscillation frequency
should be the same.
Otherwise, as a
function over time,
you cannot match the left
hand and right hand side.
And you also get a
transmitted wave.
But I'm now in trouble
because I have so many turns.
I'm summing over alpha
infinite number of turns,
and I don't know what will be
the coefficient for the r alpha
and the tau beta, which
are the transmission
coefficient and then
refraction coefficients.
So what I need to do,
as you might guess,
is to use the
boundary condition.
So now I am writing
down, already,
the general expression.
Now I'm going to use
the boundary condition
to actually limit the choice of
the possible k alpha and the k
beta.
What is actually the
boundary condition?
The boundary conditions
are that at x equal to 0--
that's actually at the
position of this line--
the membranes doesn't break.
Otherwise, suddenly
the membranes break,
and this is the end of
the discussion, right?
Like, what we have
done before, right?
So the membranes
doesn't break, so
that the propagation
can continue.
So what does that mean?
This means that if I
evaluate Psi L and Psi
r at x equal to 0, Psi 0, y, t.
The left hand side will be equal
to A exponential i, Ky times y
minus omega T, plus summing over
all possible alpha, r alpha,
A exponential i, K alpha y
times y, minus omega T. This
is the incident wave transmitted
wave evaluated at the left hand
side, which is
the upper formula.
And that will be equal
to the right hand
side, which is containing
only the transmitted wave.
So basically you
have summing over
beta, tau beta, A
exponential i, k beta,
y times r minus omega T.
And this expression,
this boundary condition,
should hold true for
all the possible y,
right, because the
boundary condition
is valid at x equal to 0.
I didn't specify the value of y.
So therefore I can actually
put in all the possible-- oh,
this should be y.
Sorry for that.
I can actually vary the y, and
I will figure out that, ah,
if I have Ky not equal
to k alpha y, that
means the wavelengths
of the refractive wave
and the incident wave
will be different.
If I have Ky not equal
to beta y that means
the transmitted
wavelengths is going
to be different from
the incident wave.
That means, no matter what
I do as a boundary of y,
the membranes will break.
Therefore, in order to
make this equation valid,
the only choice is
that when k alpha y
will be equal to k
beta y and equal to Ky.
So that means the wavelengths
projected in the y direction
should be equal for the
incident wave, transmitted wave,
and the refractive wave.
Otherwise, as you always move a
little bit in the y direction,
the membranes will break.
So that's actually the condition
which you can actually get.
And the interesting thing is
that, based on this expression,
k alpha, the length
of the k alpha,
and the length of
the k beta is fixed.
And I also know what will be the
component for the y direction.
Therefore, that means the x
direction Psi's for that k
alpha x and the k beta
x are also fixed because
of the dispersion relation.
So that immediately brings
me to this conclusion
that basically k alpha x will
be equal to minus omega squared
over v squared minus
Ky squared, and that
will be equal to minus Kx.
So this is the x component
of the refractive wave.
And the transmitting
wave, k beta x,
will be equal to square root
of omega squared over v squared
minus Ky squared.
If I draw, visualize
the relative direction
of all the three
components, basically, this
is essentially the direction
of the incident wave, k,
and the incident angle is theta.
And from this expression,
you see that the Ky
is equal to k alpha y.
Therefore, you have
a refractive wave.
But actually only the x
direction has changed sides.
Therefore, you have
a refractive wave
with exactly the same angle
as the incident angle theta.
The refraction angle
will be zeta as well.
And that there will
be a transmitted wave
with theta prime.
And this is essentially the
direction of the k prime.
And the interesting thing
is that the projection
toward the y direction,
that k prime y,
has to be equal
to the progression
of the original incident
wave in the y direction.
So that means I will be
able to conclude that--
the y components are the same.
Therefore, I can
conclude that k sine
theta will be equal to k
prime sine theta prime.
I'm kind of running out of time.
And if I define, already
as I defined here,
velocity is equal to
c over n, and the v
prime is equal to c over n
prime, what I can immediately
conclude is that--
give me one more minute--
is that if I have n equal
to c over v and the n
prime is equal to
c over v prime,
I can conclude that
sine theta will
be equal to n prime
sine theta prime.
Does this look familiar to you?
This is essentially Snell's law.
How many of you haven't
heard about Snell's law.
There were a few before.
Yeah, OK.
No problem at all.
Then you learned it.
So that means if I have two
kinds of systems in my hand,
and I will be able to relate
the transmitted wave according
to what I have in
the incident wave.
And you can see
that Snell's law--
which were famous for the
discussion of optics--
and here, I have no
knowledge about optics
or electromagnetic waves.
So in short, what I want to
tell you is that, we have just
proved two of the most important
laws of the geometrical optics,
the refraction angle is equal to
incident angle and the Snell's
law without using any
information about the dynamics.
That means all those laws are
coming from purely boundary
condition and the waves.
Therefore, you will
expect that this
will work for water wave, sound
wave, electromagnetic wave, et
cetera.
O So we will continue
the discussion next time.
Thanks for the attention.
And if you have any
questions, let me know.
I will be here.
Hello, everybody.
We are going to show you
a demonstration, a really
nice one.
It consists of the
following setup.
So basically I'm going
to place some film here.
And then behind that
there's a loud speaker,
which I use as a signal
generator and to actually
produce sound wave.
And this sound wave is going
to oscillate the soft film,
and then you are going
to see the oscillation,
or the normal mode's
pattern, on the screen.
OK, so that is
actually the setup
which we can actually
demonstrate to you two
dimensional normal modes.
So the first thing
which I am going to do
is to produce a soft film.
Now I am going to put it
back into this setup here.
You should be able to see
the pattern on the screen.
Then I am going to turn on
the sound wave generator.
You can see, immediately,
that the pattern on the screen
changed because of
the sound wave trying
to oscillate the soft film.
You can see it
directly from here,
but it actually looks much
more prominent on the screen.
And now what am I going to
do is change the frequency
of the sound wave.
And you can see
that I'm changing it
to a higher frequency.
And you can see that there is
a more and more complicated
pattern formed on the screen.
That is because I'm now exciting
higher and higher frequency
normal modes.
And you can see that now I can
actually continue and increase
the frequency.
And you can see that--
now we can see that the
pattern becomes really,
really infinitely complicated.
You can see this
grid developing.
And then you can see
that eventually that's
basically two sine functions
multiply each other.
One sine function is
in the x direction.
The other one is in the
y direction-- horizontal
and the vertical direction.
And you can see a
really beautiful pattern
forming due to the solution
we derived during the lecture.
And the higher frequency I
go, I can see more and more
complicating patterns,
many more lines
developing on the screen due to
oscillation of the soft film.
You can see now we
have even more lines.
And it's actually
getting more and more
difficult to see the pattern
because now the lines are
really close to each other.
The nodal line, we can
see clearly on the screen.
Now I am going back down
to a lower frequency,
and you can see that at
low frequency oscillation,
the number of lines
is actually smaller,
and that is because of
the smaller oscillation
frequency and the
longer wavelengths
of the normal modes.